みんな
俺の髪色見て
どう思うかい？
まあ一般的に見るとかなり明るいほうだとは思うんですけども
この写真をご覧ください
どうぞ
見てください
本来
～♬
本来俺が一番明るくいなければないけないはずなのに
多分俺は中の下ぐらいなんですよぉ！
全体で見た時に僕は多分髪の毛の明るさ中の下なんで
ダメなんですよ！！！
この色でも全然まだまだ暗いんすよ
僕が今迄で過去で一番明るくしてるくらいなんですけども
ここにさらに
もっと！もっと！
明るくしようと思ったんですけども
これだとまだまだ
みんなをまとめるテッペンとしては
というわけでなんかネットで調べたんですけど
世の中に売ってるブリーチのなかで最も強い
めちゃんこ強いといわれているブリーチを発見しました
こちらです
ハイブリーチとか明るいブリーチって
こうなんか髪の毛がキンキンの人がいると思うんですよ
まさにこういう感じね
こういう感じに女性の人とか男の人とか
髪の毛金髪でいると思うんですけども
最も強いメガブリーチには
そんな雑念が一切ございません
何たるシンプルなデザインだって思っちゃうんですけども
VividWhiphighBleachってやつですね
みてください
もう金髪要素がありません
いくとまでいけば
もう白になってしまいます
怖いよ
なんかやばいよ書いてあることやばいよこれ
なんか１剤と２剤があるんですけど
量が多いと
でいっちゃん熱いと約９０度!?
待ってｗ
約９０度まで発熱するらしいですマジで
ほらこれ大丈夫？使ってこれ
まじで怖いこれまっ大丈夫なのこれ
助けてください
怖くなってきましたが
やりましょう
というわけでこのハイベージュの金髪状態にさらに
史上最強のハイブリーチを入れると
どんな色になれるのか
まあなんせ僕はですね
このメンツより
暗いわけにはいかんのですよ
よーしなので早速使っていきましょう！
では早速やっていきましょう
あのねほんとに怖いんですけど
夏なら何色になってもいいと思うんですよ
いやだな
ホント発熱で９０度とかでたら普通に火傷しちゃうんで
マジで気を付けます
ま僕の理想は
よりきれいな金髪になればいいと思っているので
まああとはハゲたらハゲたでハゲるときはハゲます
髪の毛ぶっち切れるときは切れます
それでいいです
あぁなんかぽい
ん？
お？
なんだこれ
やっばハイブリーチこんな色なの
もう真っ白すぎてやばいんだけどこんなことなるの
やばいこれなんかすげぇハイブリーチの概念壊してる
普通ハイブリーチって金とかなんですけど
ハイブリーチより白の考えですねこっちは
え怖い
まじで怖い
まって普通のブリーチ剤こんな入ってないじゃん入れるの
１剤が５個入ってるとかばっかじゃないの
ねえ怖いよ待って
はぁ！？
待って待ってわからないわからない
１：３ってどういうこと
どやってやるのほんとに待ってだって
えぇこ
えぇ？！
まぁ頑張ってみますまじでほんとにまじで怖い
過去１番怖いですね
だって９０度とか出たら火傷するじゃん！！
まあなんせやってみましょう
とりあえず開けたら始まるってことでしょ
もういきますよ俺は
入ったはい
これを
入れます
まってどこに入れるの
まってこれどこに入れるの！？
まってこれどこに入れるの！
これに付けます
ありがとラブライブ
で混ぜます
まって熱くねこれ！？
怖いよ火傷したくないよ
うわやっぱこれ調合っていうんだね
クリーム状になったので
こいつ頭につけていきます！！
いきます！！
明るくてもそれでいいよ俺は
うぇぇ！
限りなく強い！！
まってめちゃんこ強いこれ
悪くないねぇ
時間は？
５分だやばい
時間がぁぁあ！！
計ってなかったよぉぉぉ！！！！
今からとりあえずちょっと待って
なんか明るい髪はそんなわからないけどね
いてててててて！！！
明るい髪がわからなければいいって書いてあったんで
まぁそれだけ頑張ってみればいいと思います
しばらく待ちましょバイバイ！
しーろっ
待ってください
待って白くないですか
ちょっとムラが出てしまっているんですけど
めっちゃ白い！！！！
いや分かんない
みんなと比べたらどうかわからないですけど
いやーよかったそんな
もうなんかちぎれるかと思ったんですけど
全然ちぎれずに済んでよかったんでなんとか助かりました
ありがとうございました
いやこれ以上は無理です
これ以上染めるのはもうむりです
ちょっと今年の残りの夏は
この色で乗り切ろうと思います
最後に
ママに僕の髪の毛の色を送ってあげましょう
シャッター音
どう？！
あ！返ってきた